welcome to my presentation on return on
capital let me write that down
oh i'm using the wrong color let me use
a nicer color let me go to white
let's say we had
let's go we're going to just return
on
capital
now i want to do this presentation first
because i think this this is really
going to give you the big picture on how
you should think about
what something is worth whether you
should invest your money into it and
how you should weigh the different
options you have in terms of what you
actually have to do with your money in
terms of where you want to deploy you
want to put in the bank do you want to
buy a house do you want to pay off your
credit cards etc etc so let's just
define what return on capital or um and
just so you know i'm not necessarily
going to be strict on uh the county
conventions or the gap conventions
that's uh that's kind of the kind of
conventions in this country i'm going to
do it more on a on a hands-on how you
know joe investors should think about
their money
so in this scenario i define return on
capital as just
the cash
you get
per year
divided by the cash the total cash
you put in
and well i don't want to just say cash i
could we could we could say we could
there's other ways to measure return but
actually let's just say keep it simple
let's just say cash so let's think about
how this uh works out let's say i have
an idea i have a restaurant and that
restaurant it'll cost a million dollars
it'll cost
one million dollars
investment
in this restaurant
it's gonna be a one million dollar
investment and let's say that
per year after paying
all the expenses after paying the
utility after paying the
employees after repairing and
maintenance and after paying taxes
everything let's say this restaurant
makes
one hundred thousand dollars a year
let's and that's after taxes everything
that's that's what goes into my pocket
so in this situation my return on
capital the way i've defined it is one
hundred thousand dollars
divided by
one million or we could just say a
thousand thousand dollars or equals ten
percent
ten percent pretty straightforward
you're probably saying sal this this is
silly uh why are you wasting my time
well
maybe it is but i think you'll find that
this is going to lay a foundation that
will will eventually blow your mind
so let's keep going
let me do another
okay
okay so i said the restaurant let's make
it a pizza restaurant so let's just say
the restaurant
return on capital
is equal to 10 percent
right i could put a million dollars and
i'll get in a hundred thousand dollars
per year and that's where i got a ten
percent let me write that down i get a
hundred thousand
per year
alf
of 1 million
investment
now that's that's one project and let's
just say i know for sure that i'm going
to i'm not going to
factor in things like risk and
probabilities just yet let's just say
for sure i know that if i put my money
here i'm going to get 10 on my money
and let's say the other option with my
money is a
a
a beauty parlor
beauty parlor
bu
b-e beauty
beauty parlor
a beauty parlor and let's say that that
also costs 1 million dollars
let's say that also costs one million
dollars
well and this beauty parlor gets me
fifty thousand dollars a year
fifty thousand dollars a year i think
it's very obvious to you already how
which which investment you'd rather
invest in because this the return on
capital on this beauty parlor
is only fifty thousand divided by a
million or five percent so this is
obvious you'd rather do
the restaurant than a beauty parlor and
in general if you if you um if you after
adjusting for risk you always want to go
with the project that has hot the higher
return on capital and later on you know
there'll be nuances in terms of when you
get that return maybe you'd like rather
have a slightly lower return um if you
get the money faster or or a slightly
higher return if there's um
if you're taking on risk etc etc or
to compensate for risk
so we we know we want to do the
restaurant but
do we definitely want to do the
restaurant i mean we'd rather do the
restaurant than the beauty parlor right
but my question to you is
do we definitely want to do the
restaurant and this is where the return
on on capital becomes interesting
because what matters before we put the
money into the restaurant is to think
about what the cost of that money is to
us and this is what i think will be a
little bit of a new concept to you so
i'm going to introduce you now to the
notion of a cost of capital
so let me erase this
okay
so the restaurant costs a million
dollars
cost me a million dollars
cost me one million dollars and it gives
me
one hundred thousand dollars
a year uh yep 100 000 a year and that's
a 10
return on
capital now let's say i have to borrow
all the money and there are some banks
that's willing to give me all the money
for this restaurant and the interest
rate on this loan is
let's say it's uh so let's say the loan
the interest rate
is 15 percent
is it still a good idea for me to open
up
the restaurant
well
if i if i have a loan and i have to
borrow the whole amount so i'm gonna
have a loan for one million dollars
right to buy that same restaurant
and i'm gonna be charged fifteen percent
in interest every year and i'm not going
to take taxes and the fact that you
could deduct taxes et cetera et cetera
into account just yet let's assume that
my total cost is fifteen percent per
year in interest so i'm gonna have to
spend a hundred fifty thousand dollars
per year
in interest
so my question to you is does it still
make sense for me to open up this
restaurant every year i'm going to be
making a hundred thousand dollars from
the restaurant itself but i'm going to
be paying 150 000
a year
in interest
so you probably say sal once again you
have just restated the obvious no you
would not want to do this restaurant
because every year 50 000
will be burning out of your pocket now
you might think that this is obvious but
i'm going to show you many many examples
of where people are actively doing this
people who you would otherwise assume
could could do this type of math and
it's especially happening in the housing
market but anyway so in this situation
you wouldn't want invested and a very
simple way of thinking about this is you
would only want to invest you only want
to do a project if your return
return on capital
is greater than let's say we could call
it your then your cost of capital
cost of capital
this is the only time that you want to
invest in a project
with that said i'm not going to go
back to what we just did i i just showed
you something that we thought was
obvious but i'm gonna i'm gonna
re-ask you a question
so we had the restaurant
and we have the beauty parlor let's call
it bp for short they both cost a million
dollars
right roc
the roc of the restaurant we said was 10
percent
and the roc on the beauty parlor we said
was 5 so right now superficially it
looks like the restaurant is just a
better
project
but then we said the cost of capital so
the interest rate
which is our how much does it cost for
us to get that million dollars the
interest rate to borrow money for a
restaurant is 15
and we said that this is not a good
investment because our cost of capital
is higher than our return on capital and
you could do the math and figure it out
but what if there was some kind of
government program that they just felt
that
there weren't enough beauty parlors in
the country and they were willing to
give you a really cheap loan to buy a
beauty parlor and the government program
they said we're going to give you a low
interest loan of two percent
huh so my question to you is now which
project would you rather do
superficially it looks like the
restaurant was better you get you get a
10 return as opposed to a 5
but your cost of capital the interest
rate you would have to pay on a loan for
the beauty parlor all of a sudden looks
a little bit better
in fact this is actually a good
investment because your cost of capital
is less than your return on capital we
can even do the math every year the
beauty parlor will generate fifty
thousand dollars
and you'll be paying
twenty thousand dollars in interest so
you'll be netting thirty thousand
dollars without having to put any money
for yourself you'll be borrowing all the
money so clearly this is a good
investment
so that's it now for the intro on return
on capital and cost of capital and my
next presentations i'll go into a little
bit more detail and do a few more
nuanced examples